scènes de guérilla à peine une dizaine
de kilomètres du centre de new delhi
depuis trois jours cette partie de la
capitale indienne est le théâtre de
violents affrontements
ce qui était au départ des
manifestations contre une loi sur la
citoyenneté jugé discriminatoire s'est
transformée en lutte armée entre
nationalistes hindous et musulmans
véhicules magasins et maisons incendiées
une situation qui pousse les habitants à
fuir craignant pour leur vie
les hôtels ferment les usines ferment
qu'allons nous faire
les gens m'appellent de mon village ils
sont tous inquiets qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
il vaut mieux partir que rester ici
pourquoi voudrions-nous mourir ici les
gens s'entretuent des balles pleuvent
j'ai vu des affrontements dans le
quartier depuis ce matin et je quitte la
maison pour cela et une population qui
dénonce l'inaction des forces de l'ordre
depuis hier nous demandons à la police
d'appliquer un couvre-feu d'envoyer des
renforts mais personne n'est venu
il n'y a que trois policiers on a appelé
la police plusieurs fois depuis deux ans
de bagues les gens scandaient gloire au
seigneur ram est rentré dans le quartier
mais la police ne nous a pas du tout
aidé pour tenter de contenir
l'embrasement un couvre-feu a été imposé
dans ses quartiers depuis hier soir le
premier ministre n'a rien drame audi a
appelé au calme ce matin sur twitter la
paix et l'harmonie sont au coeur de
notre philosophie
j'invite mes soeurs et frères de délits
à maintenir la paix et la fraternité en
tout temps il est important qu'il y ait
calme et que la normalité soit rétabli
au plus tôt parmi les responsables
indiens des voix s'élèvent pour
condamner la passivité des autorités
la présidente du parti du congrès sonia
gandhi réclament la démission du
ministre de l'intérieur
[Musique]